few years back i opened for kendrick
lamar and the the front monitors was off
and they said the monitor was off so the
audience wasn't hearing what i was doing
so i'm just going hard as i don't know
what no there's no reactions my friends
come back you killed it bro but let me
just tell you the monitors were awesome
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez okay let's do the
show because i got a lot of things to do
i gotta go to that directly right here
my kid phelps
sport sport and paul
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george
bespoke post partners with small
businesses and emerging brands to bring
you in the most unique goods every month
no matter what you're into
their box of awesome has you covered get
20 percent off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome.com
and enter the code omghi
at checkout
i used a garmin bag this last weekend
and it was so easy to carry so easy to
get it on the plane and it had
everything i needed for my show as a
matter of fact if my luggage hadn't made
it to the town that i was going to i had
everything in that bag that i needed for
the show there you go
i'm down the ground wow plug me back in
i'm back so can it work the other way
around can you get the adrenaline to
make you actually lift the cars and
stuff [ __ ] i have trouble lifting my fat
ass
that's hard
wow
that's what goes on so i just go down i
get up and i'm back at it so he gave me
this
and i'm just telling the wife yesterday
since i've had this thing i hadn't have
once it just came on too quick i said uh
not even this is going to say make sure
to shut up
was that the first time that you went
down to this whole almost the whole year
uh it's the first time i've gone down
since you gave me the stick
oh wow
it's a good stick yeah it's a great
stick didn't pass out didn't do anything
the only adjustment was you put a little
rubber tip on the end that's it that's
it you know that helps to make it good
for you know slick just right right
feels like south africa
i'm an expert in the field yeah it's
like something it's a good height that
feels good doesn't it yeah i gotta get
my wife one of those for like when the
coyotes chase her on a [ __ ] hike
yeah it's like 4 30 in the morning i
went outside i said oh what do you got
and then i went like this and the other
one started to go around me oh wow he's
trying to flank you how many wow
that's your backyard you're walking in
two yeah my front yard in the driveway
oh i said hey what's going on over here
and then this one went that way and then
i looked this way and that one was going
well i don't think two would try me all
right i think i would need at least four
my wife got one could take you my wife's
got lucky she's brazilian she's because
she's got that brazilian butt and she
had two of them scoping her on the hill
seriously 10 feet away from her and they
literally were just like
and she was like
what should you lose all that energy
come over here and introduce
are we ready yeah
oh what are these
that's my own uh concoctions yes yes i
put one in front of you sure yeah
that's beer try out the beers yeah we
have george lopez brand beers
i don't drink beer but i'll have one in
front of me and act like yeah that's
good how about that try it
yeah joining us today on the podcast we
have the cast of the upcoming film north
of the 10. george you'll be able to tell
us a little more about that once we get
started but we've got adam w de storm
power and yancy arius yo real cat
how do
um how did this movie north of 10 get
made i mean this movie this movie is
going to be it's one of those things
where
a movie doesn't have to have a real big
budget to be good i know this one's
going to be good how does how does this
movie get
get made a lot of favors no yeah not a
favor
it might be no but how does how does it
really get made well see yeah so don
benjamin uh several years ago started
writing this story for himself
it's it's his story with his friends and
don benjamin is one of the bigger
influences out there and these guys here
d stone power mr adam w these guys have
a great following and they all work
together so it's it's a wonderful thing
that we get them all on film and have
this like amazing you know authentic
chemistry that you had that that comes
from all this great comedy that's
happening so don benjamin was having the
movie written
and he wrote on it as well and ryan
lamar who was our director creator he
brought your mind yeah and young
director yep and he he and uh and about
two other guys they got together with
with don and they formulated a very good
script a lot a lot of uh wonderful
moments in there and bringing in actors
like yourself and myself to come in
there and and join the fl you know the
the the fray of the the traitor the
trailer is very funny what's the premise
of the of the film
well uh the premise of the film is five
guys
trying to make it in l.a they're trying
to get north of you know in every
neighborhood or in every hood you try to
make it to that spot in la it's like you
want to make it north of a certain place
so norfolk the tennis when you get
norfolk to 10 you made it so it's five
guys with different jobs there's the
gamer there's the chef you know there's
the actor there's the model and these
guys are trying to just make it north of
the 10 but they're going through all
these problems and and these struggles
that you know roommates and people go
through so that's the purpose of the
movie
and the essence of the film is never
quit never give up you know just there
you go follow your dreams you know great
advice do your thing um it it it
it looks very expensive but but
was it yeah yeah the house is the house
looks good the trailer looks i mean it's
immaculate sure it was good i was clean
very funny yeah
yeah well i hear that the country of
dubai had a wonderful contribution to
the film and the way that it was the uae
we did uh uh abu dhabi abu dhabi abu
dhabi so it was it was we went to abu
dhabi and they let us use the palace
they let us use the mosque they let us
use the raceway they let us use what was
it like
the ferrari world we did the um it's the
biggest uh
water world in the water park in the
world so they let us use all that stuff
because of our audience and we would
definitely talk about it on our social
so they so in a sense they did it for
the the
product placement publicity and
publicity yeah in a way yeah so when we
went out there they they rolled out the
red carpet for us and they let us they
just i wish i shot my scenes out there
so you guys had a contact over there you
land
and they say hey we're ready to start
working and you they shot in the palace
they shot
yeah pretty much had the run of the a
quarter of the film takes place there
and it's like elijah's over there one
another producer and a few of the other
producers are over there and they
they're producers on the movie so they
kind of like hooked it up we did like
international things pretty amazing yeah
stephanie nur who is our lead actress of
the film she uh she was a she was able
to film out there as well and she
brought a wonderful authentic sense of
the the culture of of being in in that
situation a girl coming to america
falling in love with this model you know
so you have this romantic comedy you
know going wrapped around a love story
wrapped around a love story and so she
got a chance to shoot out there too and
and i'm sure you guys had a lot of fun
you know
letting her you know introduce you to
that world and whatnot right yeah my
only thing about the film is like so
many jokes we told and i know you only
have a certain amount of time to do it
because we were we were cutting up we
were kind of [ __ ] out for it so i mean
we had enough to make two movies yes and
it's very hard to truncate it and get it
down to one it's going to be it's going
to be i haven't seen it yes but i think
when you get to the point where you can
put
extra content on on your sites
or you know as part of uh a vibe thing
you know you buy extra content even
right because the one thing that i
noticed about
the guys over there in chicago as the
[ __ ] are funny as [ __ ] yeah
yeah young and listen when i was young
nobody was [ __ ] funny that's how i
made it
10 dudes you guys would be funny
but but man you know those guys are just
so good with each other you guys are so
good with each other yeah and i mean
that's
you know in a movie like that
to have that ability to be able to make
things good better yeah and things that
are already good to say we're happy
we're happy like solid so i'm interested
to see how it comes out because
everything is shot well you can see the
scope of it they go to dubai they go
they go to chicago they got
kind of a
show going on of the guys living
together right right right well and then
you know ryan lamar our director he he
is from chicago and he definitely has
that flavor where you know you show up
you got a blueprint you guys you know
have a script but but go for it and see
what happens what type of director do
you think uh ryan lamar is going to be
end up being because i think you know
it's when you see some guys that
you're
you're around early right but then you
know that down the line that this guy is
going to be
be a big director well for for me i i
think with ryan he's so talented because
he does music as well so he's he's a
producer he's a director um actually his
produce production hat is bigger than
his director hat to me i've seen him
produce things and i'm like wow this guy
he doesn't miss a beat but when it comes
to his directing i think uh
his drama is his bag
you know seeing him do step outside of
the drama because he did canal street he
did another drama to see him step out of
that bag and then do a comedy for me
it's like you know it's different so i'm
like i'm just interested to see how it
comes out and because of the music he's
got the flow yeah yeah the cool thing
too i think he's a real actors director
too because even like when i got on set
he was like just say whatever you want
i was like all right
that's what happens that's how we shoot
like when we shoot we just improv yeah
so when you see it back in the days
they would if you said the instead of we
come over and you go you said
[Laughter]
one of those guys huh
do it again it's we yeah yeah not the
okay that's how they used to be to us
and now now it's a new game though i
think you know
you know
and i also feel like scorsese you know
is one of those directors that that
opened up for the young guys like pacino
and de niro who was you know now let's
let's do it a hundredth time and this
time just give me a different you know
take on it joe pesci told me that when
they had heard about him in the hood in
the neighborhood and they said there's
this guy that would be great he's not an
actor
and and he would be great to play the
brother
so they sent him the script
and he reads it and he calls it up
there's no i'm not even in this [ __ ]
busy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so he didn't call he didn't he didn't
call back so two weeks later
i'm not even in it
so they had a manager
a boxing manager they were they took
that part out and combined the brother
with the boxing manager and then they
made his part but how about a guy that's
never done a movie before wow
and he reads it he's like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
i'm not in it
and then he went to
he went to a guy
that was a guy from the neighborhood
and and they had to go and talk to him
and and he said
is this what you want to do joe and he
goes
yeah you know it's kind of been my thing
because okay go take a little money
and good luck if you need anything here
i am again a blessing to go because you
just can't pull the dude out of the
neighborhood
you know no and he said that's what you
want to do and he said yeah that's what
i want making too much money in the hood
yeah
yeah so so uh
yeah and then you came on to the set and
you blessed we've known each other for a
long time
yeah i mean that was
it's good it's nice to help and thank
and thank you i appreciate you guys
you're definitely godfathered us and i
love you for that
welcome i'm happy to be able to do that
thank you man yeah and where i'm working
people where are we going to see this uh
b-e-t plus you'll be able to stream it
there's a b-e-t plus yes plus everything
now i know plus everything
and that's where we'll be streaming on
the 10th just a few days from today okay
just a few days from
is the seventh that's three days from
now yeah so this is a movie that appeals
to
i remember i don't want to drop names
but when i was talking to paul walker
about fast and furious the whole the
whole franchise and i said so what you
guys essentially did was made a film for
everybody to go see themselves
in
in beauty like the girls are beautiful
the dudes were handsome in cars and he's
like yeah pretty much and i mean it when
he when he walked out there
and the amount of love that came towards
them it's just like whoever is turning
the knobs to say this is what we want
this movie to be was what's doing it
right and it's still going it's still
still gone
what are they like on par 20 now 4 20
exactly
yeah it's still going and paul walker's
brother's in it too right yeah i think i
mean it's a little out of control but
it's still good i'll say this all it's
good every every each one i have been
upset at any of them they're all good
who's not going to like cars and girls
i heard there was like some tension
between uh mr uh vin diesel and the rock
oh yeah yeah dwayne johnson on the news
and now he's trying to now he's trying
to bring him back to the film and
wayne's like trying to guilt him but
they're coming back
saying no i don't want no part of it
gracefully no i hope they replace him
with me i mean right now
they asked me but i told him i was busy
with george
no you told me you couldn't get up my
manager matt luber he he represented
paul walker all his life and and uh it
was it was it was a great loss to the
community and to him and and but but it
was a beautiful thing that they tried to
bring his family back into the movie i
think his brother's playing like several
several pieces into the the franchise in
the last parts of the franchise but on
this one yes it's definitely a lot of
glam there's a lot of playing there's a
lot of beauty and and and a lot of fun
like these guys i mean are stupid funny
every time i i i can't get off an uh
instagram every time i watch these guys
yeah like
i got to feed the kids wait hold on a
second oh my god you son of a gun so so
so uh uh is it the ninth you said
the tenth yeah so the tenth you you can
get it on your phones you can get it on
your laptops you get it yeah i think
they decide to go with the tenth because
it's called north of the 10th north of
the city yeah
they say you can't forget that you can't
forget that right yeah yeah i'm writing
time for valentine's too you know so i
think some of the guys are there at the
premiere in atlanta right now as we
speak they did a premiere in atlanta
it's going right now right now
and uh with movies like that that are
released like this is is there
uh are they tracking the numbers to see
uh is there an awareness can they track
awareness for this or they can they can
you know they have a very talented crew
in terms of the publicity and in terms
of
but pretty much the distribution the
people go the people find this
well
amazon plus i i think after a week on
plus it's going straight to cable so
it's going to be
like every it's going to straight come
out right universally right so they're
going to get it on plus so people on
plus can get it then they'll go straight
to bt regular cable so it'll stream even
to a larger audience and it's going to
be in select theaters did you guys know
each other before
well we we haven't this is our first
time i've known this guy for some years
where did you guys grow up
i grew up born and raised in new york
queens flushing oh that's where i grew
up the girl was here from queensland
i grew up in baltimore then when i was
1920 i moved to new york for 10 years
and then i came to la you moved to new
york to do what
music i was in the music business for
six years and then after the music
business i went into social media you
want to listen to this and call gem
where you weren't the other dude nah nah
that was before but my time i don't know
they look like uncle that was
the best
time and what time of music was it like
what was popping up in new york at that
time uh
because everything that was coming out
jc 50 cent was new it was like new music
like
george gershwin and and irving berlin
like they were creating new music right
and in that area at that time
biggie and
and uh you know
um you know all the guys it was like it
was like two
2005
six seven sort of been going yeah so it
was it was in the early twenties i'm
feeling old now i'm thinking freestyle
and hip-hop when you guys are talking
about man you buy a refrigerator
going to be in the halftime show at
super bowl
it's a big big secret they're talking
about for real to
[Music]
what do you hear what do you hear about
the halftime show i i didn't hear
anything about the halftime show i
didn't know yeah it's very very private
isn't it i i think
because it's in los angeles maybe you'll
agree or disagree
i i don't think they can make a mistake
with the halftime show yeah no way
unless they do it on purpose it's all
right because it lets it go but it's
already
losing its you know yeah it's bigger
yeah because they try to put people
together that don't
that they don't belong together right
well that's because
one of the performers
uh not the female not snoop dogg
one of the other performers that's going
to be up there just say one of the black
people come on you know you want to i'd
like to but look at that joe rogan
50 cent is the guy that broke him in
and led him along brought him you know
his protege
and so they're saying
50 cent would be on her just to and they
asked 50 cent and all he did was smile
and say well i i don't know he'll see
what happens he's going to be honest i
think that's only 12 minutes maybe
it's a it's a very short i bet look at
prince prince
killed it played all along the
watchtower
one song that was in his wait the show
is only 12 minutes the halftime show
it's short really it feels like they're
30 minutes
no no there's no thirty minutes
in 1993 at the rose bowl i was there
when michael jackson
uh performed at the halftime show oh wow
how was that
amazing wow
because they had they had the michael
jackson's pop up in the four corners
wow of of uh before time
and a guy pops up and you know he's
doing that right and another guy and
another guy michael jackson's probably
the only person i want to see at a
halftime show it was pretty amazing yeah
that's it
yeah did i see i saw michael jackson and
then i at the 49ers stadium i saw
beyonce and the guy from coldplay and we
saw that i saw that one
when beyonce was out there with the
dancers i love beyonce kicking ass the
mobile came out from coldplay
boston lost them yeah
bruno mars and beyonce and then
they do try to cut in between like hey
i'm here too and then
they're like no
kayla did it i think it came back
like
yeah i thought she was out of her
element
the weekend was dope last year that was
weekend last year right it was weekend
it was it was everybody with like the
weekend
bandages it was it was a week scary yeah
scary it's gotta be i would say it's
gotta be maybe
um send somebody big for live events
gotta be the biggest thing to be able to
do
at this particular time i can't imagine
even like because i performed on stage
on broadway for like six years and we we
would have like these little comms and
stuff and sometimes if we don't hear
something
it ain't gonna come out that way so like
i can only imagine what it must be like
for like having thousands of thousands
of people we only had two thousand a
night these guys have what twenty
thousand a lot you know the whole world
watching and everything echoing all over
you and then they're trying to perform
at the same time i'm trying to keep it
simple the worst feeling a few years
back i opened for kendrick lamar and the
the front monitors was off and they said
the monitor was off so the audience
wasn't hearing what i was doing so i'm
just going hard as i don't know what no
there's no reactions and my friends come
back you killed it bro but let me just
tell you the monitors were off
i couldn't hear you
no no no no audience i'm like they're
not feeling the music at all but we had
the dancers back there sweating and
everything we had nights when where
might where the sound was off and i had
to scream my songs like to the balcony
where i was like oh my god and the
audience you can feel it the audience
shuffling around like what's he saying
yeah i'm like i'm on stage you know
trying to give him a 100 what's the
universal uh
what's the universal code when some [ __ ]
goes wrong to just keep dancing don't
stop gotta keep pretending they can hear
you
keep singing try to find the producer or
the dj
and try to get his attention and you do
something to let them know something's
wrong and if you don't sometimes you
have to say to save yourself you have to
say cut the music man yeah he [ __ ] up
you blame him
you got to blame it on something what
the [ __ ] why did you stop dancing i
couldn't hear [ __ ] everybody else
[ __ ] kept dancing yeah that's why i
stopped doing the moonwalk on stage
you got to blame somebody because you
don't want them to say you you [ __ ] up
when you didn't but this is a big week
for for uh big week for the movie yes
and big week for los angeles and i mean
it's it's it's a hit film you know so
it's uh
it's back in l.a
that's amazing travis is going to be
crazy traffic
perhaps you know i don't know what they
did during the olympics was the 84
olympics when they had him here last
time they staggered the working hours
yeah and then traffic went down to
it was nothing sorry he wasn't born it's
okay yeah
i missed that pandemic traffic that was
the best you know that you know that
gill captured the richard ramirez
nightstalker yeah what
he's a detective that captured the
nightstalker the same guy you saw
flopping on the floor
one time i was on my feet i was just
watching i think i was just watching
that tim
that's you yeah get out of here no [ __ ]
[ __ ] that
he was the guy that said it's one guy
and then all the other sheriff said no
it's got [ __ ] two guys three guys he
said this is the work of one guy wow
there was no copycats or anything like
that and there were no copycats there
they hadn't been a copycat since nobody
knows what he was really doing wow and
he was the most difficult eyes with him
and [ __ ] i mean
he'll be taking some of those
yeah there you go that's crazy wow and
he said that
you know women
i don't know man like women love him
are you doing
one day you know he had people going in
to see the court case everything
shades on and he'd go like this for
girls you know you know and he'll come
up to him
he was gonna go sit at the side he'd
walk out first thing he'd do is he
checked the audience see who the
good-looking women are
and he wasn't allowed to turn his head
around so you just look check it out
go sit down put his back to him and
now when it's time for him to walk out
he kind of yeah now he's looking at the
one he wanted he'd already picked one
out of the herd wow so he's out there
well one day i'm in there
and they call me up
they let me know hey there's a phone
call for you with the
over here with the uh bailiff as i said
so i go in there
and
well i'm sitting there looking here
comes richard as he's coming out
and there are these two ladies they were
no doubt in my mind they were attorneys
they were dressed to the teds they were
both beautiful
little briefcases there
trust me they were good looking
and one of them was sitting on the aisle
and as he's walking out he looks at her
she looks at him
she blows him a kiss and spreads her
legs
what was he attracting dude well
the beauty's in the eye of the beholder
you know
so i just went back to my partner i said
[ __ ] hook me up see if it works for
me too
but you know some women like i mean i
can't imagine a woman like a bad dude
like that right but come home with your
eyes gone yeah you know
he was a bad boy he was powerful you
know he was and he ended up married a
very ugly
bad woman you know
i don't know if she was bad what made
what made him that way what what do you
think because of uh
the the the
his childhood i have no idea he asked me
one time
why do you think i am the way i am gil
and i just i said ranch if i had if i
knew what you why you are the way you
are i'd be a doctor making a lot more
money than i am as a cop drugs in the
beginning my job is not to make
understand why my job is to get you
convicted you still like that you know
he's dead oh wow
januar or june 7th 2013. this is how
notorious he was he did 20 years and
when he died the people complained that
he didn't do a long enough time he's
dead
he's done he said it
his dad used to beat him as a kid as a
child his dad used to beat him he said
run away that
i i laughed at him because he'd run away
from home and he'd go spend the night in
the cemetery
because it was peaceful and quiet
pretty quiet there yeah and obviously
next to the cemetery you'll be hearing
some [ __ ] like i said how the [ __ ] could
you go around
that's getting the [ __ ] no no it's
peaceful
don't raise your children near the
cemetery his spree
if you had to
he was arrested
august 31st of 85.
when we went back to do everything we
found that he had killed the lady in l.a
in
june of 1984. so it was one
and then nothing until march
and then in march between march 17 85
killed 13 people
did y'all get all the bodies
yeah we got all the bodies in there and
not only was he
killing people he was
also a child mostly pedophile so he's
kidnapping little girls kidnapping
little boys you know he he had his way
so
that's why there's no copycats nobody
knew
everything he was doing and he was using
uh as weapons guns knives you know where
all that [ __ ] happens
what's the distribution on
on the face everywhere right so yes so
basically bt plus they carry us and then
uh we'll be on cable with bt but then
beyond that you'll be able to get us on
amazon netflix hopefully they're working
out those deals right now the numbers
have to be right and the numbers i think
they will be so so if it opens strong it
will continue to get places to be seen
absolutely and there's some there's ryan
has been around now for quite a bit and
he has been able to because of the
success of canal street and uh restored
me you know people are trusting him he
worked with guys like will smith and his
brother you know uh and their smith
global so people understand that okay
he's making some really good content and
we got this amazing situation now where
like we created you know a situation
where a space where influencers were
really good actors really good comedians
making movies coming in and you know
joining the world of entertainment in
the film side you know i think i think
we're going to have a great audience and
and you know uh really fun whose music
is in there you have music in here i did
three well so what ryan did was he
decided to take the musicians that do
make music like myself don benjamin
himself and a few others to do like
their own small eps so i have like three
records on in the in the film good and
and i it was good to see him in my scene
so that's kind of him
yeah i think don't have a few we
recorded a a a cool music video with
george to to close oh yeah we're going
to jump in and out with some some
snippets of the film kind of like you
know easter eggs and
you know outtakes and uh
it's called it's called um paramigente
but it's a it's a different it's a
different i think more more inclusive
way to make movies right yeah because
you if you go to if you go to the
theater you see the movie then you leave
and it leaves with you but if you
own it you buy it rent it i just i think
it feels a little more personal yeah for
sure for sure and i i i mean yeah those
were the days right when we used to have
yeah i still have my collection of dvds
you still have your blockbuster's car i
know that i don't have that but i
definitely have my dvd
and i tell my kids don't touch it that's
like golden block
red box when red box came along because
you could get it outside you have to go
inside
weren't even around long enough well not
enough yeah he's around long enough to
[ __ ] everything up and take off
netflix [ __ ] up red box yeah there you
go there you go
this winter upgrade your daily routine
with bespoke post and their new seasonal
lineup of must-have box of awesome
collections
bespoke post partners with small
business and emerging brands to bring
you the most unique goods every month um
yeah a lot of people do this with like
beer and they do it with different
products but
this one
bespoke um sent me some knives different
sizes amazing for the house
outside stuff you know camping and stuff
and um it was great some knives and i
used it uh to open some things around
the house i used it to cut some rope in
the backyard and to trim a little bit of
some unsightly things i had growing
but we smoked all those so it is great
to get such a unique quality product
while supporting small businesses which
is more important that we continue to
support small businesses and every month
you get something that's very different
and very unique get 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com and enter the code
omghi at checkout that's box of
awesome.com code
h omghi for 20
off your first box
you know when i was on the radio in 2000
a guy came in from san francisco
and he had an idea for this company that
if you remember
you sent in your request and they sent
you an envelope with the movie in it oh
yeah then you had three days and you'd
send it back that was netflix right that
was yeah see i want to watch uh you know
a police academy they send it to you at
three days you put it back in the
envelope and send it back and he was
down here
in l.a looking for investors
nobody interesting wow don't you wish
you were that guy
i missed a couple opportunities
in the 80s i was working at van nuys and
there was a guy that followed the stock
market every day but wouldn't wouldn't
put his own money in i said ted what the
[ __ ] you doing he goes i don't know
george i might have to go for this one
man what do you think and it was he said
you know however you have everything in
your
garage in your house you can't get to
anything any of it so this is an idea
where they build
stalls
and then you rent the stall and you go
over there and you put your stuff in the
stall they give you the key and you can
go and open it and get what you need and
close it again and they charge you a
rental fee like storage units i said
[ __ ] who's going to do that
like that that's what i said saline is
never going to work oh no sure
let's try three try three wow
man you just never know it's just nice
timing too is timing man it's like
storage that's rough that's a big one
yeah and the guy didn't put any money in
it either
and i mean it was just it was it was at
the ground level that's right
and he had money
and the other one was um
they did floppy disks for main computers
that were probably that size and then
the company that i worked for
was doing a hard drive and he was going
around to the employees asking if they
wanted to put money into a personal
computer that you that would you take
with you right and everybody's like why
would you take a [ __ ] computer with
you got it at home
i pentecost imagine man
imagine wait so you dropped the ball in
the lap [ __ ] forward
that's right god if i haven't become
[ __ ] successful i'd [ __ ] be out
there right hey hey i'm [ __ ] dicks
all you got
three dollars
two damn i mean imagine that four
[ __ ] great opportunities right yeah i
know i know it's crazy
you might get one though oh for sure
you'll get one good one
i'm sure you got something you don't
want to talk about
it required somebody to die but yes oh
no
uh but you know
in our life you know who's just who's to
say yeah all the guys that i admired
looking at some documentaries last night
they said hey that dude spent every
dollar he ever made you seem happy
i mean who's to say i mean when as you
get older
you know he was in vietnam you know i
spent every dollar i made it's like you
know you have to you have to take
those days like this like we all work
together we're in chicago everybody got
along really really great experience you
get to see it come out i'll buy it i'll
tell my friends to buy to put it on my
social media but it's in in that time
like i've seen
you know hundreds of movies come and go
but as you get to where guys start to
make them and it's really what they love
to do they're not they're not guys that
don't aren't hands-on like in the
beginning a guy who put some money in
and then he'd be going like what are we
doing now right right we're going again
you know now the guys are hands-on they
know what they're doing right yeah i
hate that [ __ ] man when actors they put
out they they don't have the passion
anymore like bruce did that to me man i
loved his movies and now it's like i
watch a bruce willis movie i'm like man
come on i know man what's he doing what
happened the [ __ ] are you doing bro like
he was my favorite now he's just doing i
mean i know you got to pay bills but
come on bro i got i got a funny story
about this
so i'm doing live free or die hard and i
i'm stuck in a car with him with all
these cameras around us and we can't get
out of the car for about three hours
so we're hanging and we know we're in
for the long haul and he's you know
cracking jokes and i'm like
yo this is not funny at one point i'm
like
i just i stopped him on the on the leg
you know by just at a chest like oh yeah
and he was like don't ever touch me
again i was like
[Laughter]
one of those moments like it's like
frozen you just like you're laughing
your butt off and you're like oh [ __ ]
like i just got kicked in the nuts you
know i'm like okay i'm sorry man you
know when you see it when you see a guy
like that
because you know
it's an actor like he went in
and got moonlighting in the in the 80s
you know just the guy was a bartender
yeah goes in there gets moonlighting
becomes a big tv star becomes a movie
star but really is as a bartender who
got a gig and then got another gig and
blew up but at some point
those guys
are the guy like hey don't ever touch me
again you know the guy
[Laughter]
a friend of a mutual friend uh she dated
bruce at one point and she said and i
told her the story she goes oh yeah he
has a thing with his leg i was like oh
it's just like oh you're good yeah all
right so i could have went in his arm
and if we would hit him
but it was like with his leg i was like
i didn't know sorry man yeah
maybe thesis he
maybe he should produce films
yeah because i think he if he if he's
not
if he's not passionate about yeah
because a buddy of mine said he shot one
of his new you know he's doing like
those those west
what on
and um he said uh buddy of i said he was
shooting with bruce and he said wait we
had boost for eight hours
i'm like you're going to see the whole
movie you got it for a sec yeah he came
in shot all his parts and then yeah
that's right that's right and he gets in
he gets out in eight hours like every
party they do two days yeah you gotta
shoot all this stuff in two days that's
all he had
like four hours one day four hours the
next day and he was out well yeah and
that's that's the deal a lot of times
with the you know big actors like george
lopez you know we sometimes we gotta get
him in and get him out
and we expect so much of you he's like
here's here's the here's was i there
only one day you were there one day okay
we filled you in and we and knocked you
out in one day and you're [ __ ]
driving me up some guy from the ukraine
i said this [ __ ]
and on the way back he was telling me
about a boat that he was building so he
could he could he could um
sail as a living for a living like sale
and i sent him a thousand dollars
oh that was so beautiful
in the morning i couldn't [ __ ] stand
him oh man by the night and then
when he started to talk to tell me the
story and the passion that he had about
building the ship by hand
like a small little wooden boat you want
me to drive you anytime
that's a reality show right there show
us your passion god damn it there you go
yeah yeah yeah
there you go i gotta tell you how actors
you know
you people that are put those you know
what you want to say
people are nice i'm gonna give a shout
out right now to the people over at
point the hill show okay
bye because they get
i i went in there
and when they went in there somebody
recognized me from the
documentary
and they were all tired so give them
pictures they said
floyd merriweather went in there
marijuana mary
mayweather went in there bought three
cars
and his guy that was with him said let's
get one thing straight right now
no autographs no pictures nobody come up
and talk to him damn he's buying three
cars that's it he's in he's out
and
they'll never forget that
and yet they were saying and you were so
nice you know you did this you did that
so these guys that spend their time
bruce willis don't touch me right i
guess there are people you know people
that go on the set only spend one day
and then
get out of there but then
there's people that fire other people
too and you never know
they're walking you out right they're
walking down you know let's close the
door they're like
this is it this is it's my last show i
don't know but they do you know that
they do that really oh dude
so i got him i got him i got a quick
mayweather story me and me in batch king
batch we went to um vegas because that's
where he was living at to shoot a vine
it's back when vine was huge so we get
to his house and we we i mean we were
downstairs for like an hour remember
what was the 15 seconds it's like six
seconds six six so we're at his house
and he we waited downstairs for about an
hour we never met him yet or whatever so
we finally hook up with him so he's like
i gotta go to the bank so we go to the
bank and it's me floyd and bash we're
walking over there and it's these two
big security guards this is random
character way down the block and we're
like yo there's some guy watching us
he's like oh no no i don't worry about
him that's the shooter i was like
what so he has like a random guy who
stands a hundred feet away with just
like a pistol and just watches
to make sure that nothing happens and
he's just this is this other security
guy that he has with him because you
know there's a lot of people that you
know
mess with the guys right it was just
crazy i was like you know that is a it
is a trip home yeah so he has it has a
wild security guard he's always got his
money with him right never wearing money
to see all next to those dudes like his
roll up on him like he was that this yo
next was like in the place looking at
motorcycles i think
him and a buddy were looking at
motorcycles and then these guys walked
in and they looked at him
yeah and they were like
you know not today
he kind of knew something was
wasn't right i mean you know you know it
looks like they belong in that in that
thing yeah right right no one is off but
you need those type of people around
though it makes sense i think you do man
[ __ ] i mean it happened so fast yeah it
happened so fast you know when you're on
that level for sure you gotta you know
you gotta secure what you gotta say
you've never reached that level
they rolled they roll with a lot of
money they were you were the shooter
what do you mean
so you didn't have to how's that beer
good
it's actually really it's pretty good
though it's really good this one is
which one uh is this one grant
the lager
i started brewing these uh
in torrance and then we had to open the
place in hermosa is it hell getting your
own um beer cup it is smooth it is
smooth uh
looks like you locked one to this
but yeah yeah uh chicago hard on the
thing but you know but you know what it
what it does is uh two north of the 10
right here
is i had a good brewer like the guy
worked at stone brewing for like thirty
three years
this is why i love this
i go in there and i said hey man
remember those ice creams that were like
orange and cream in the middle 50 50
yards
wow i go can you make a beer that tastes
like that he goes
uh yeah i can make a bread taste like
that
and then there's one that is what uh uh
like squirt that grapefruit oh and
there's one that i the hibiscus one
biscuit there's one hibiscus what what
is the hamika amica check this out oh so
hamaika they use they they put tequila
and vodka they look at this the ipa
you're right that smells that's right
oh that's ip we're not we don't have the
orange ones yeah they're out of both of
them they're the people's favorites
right now [ __ ] the people one
show a week
so how much time do you spend on on
making the beer like like you actually
go out to the brewery and you sit there
and you mix up mess it up with these
guys so much not so much oh yeah once a
week
but uh but they can them there
and then we just went to a different uh
i think a place in colorado's gonna do
it and then distribute it and keep track
of it but i think they can they're
talking about making the can 12 ounce
which is this is a more of a 16 or 18.
so they're a little bit smaller you
don't have bottles it's all cans it's
all
well yeah i mean it's cool because i
love i love the low rider in there look
at that you guys look at this beautiful
bottles yeah yeah they do bottled water
tastes better than canned water than me
you tried box water
i have it's the best no
because because the fizz doesn't stay in
the box
i don't know it's about the texture
coming off the cardboard you got to try
it well the place you're thinking about
that you should do boxed beer box beer
there is box berry running in there
with that [ __ ] party ball or some
[ __ ] that everybody's talking about they
put they put nine cakes into a little
[ __ ] thing that's that big you'd be
the first one to do box beer yeah come
on i'll invest
the environment don't miss it love it
but we talked about it yeah man
i'll miss this opportunity remember
remember the coors party ball
oh you thought it was a boxing ball
yeah i remember that i remember that did
you guys drink in vietnam
no i drank whiskey in vietnam the royal
crown was cheap
they should drink royal cattle
you could royal crown was nothing there
was a beer called was it crazy horse is
that right something really never crazy
crazy wine
i came out of college i got miss saigon
i celebrated with a buddy of mine he's
like let's get crazy and i said okay so
i took the whole thing i drink drank it
down and and i was like that's nothing
half hour later i was like
i just got hit and like i got hit with
him what's the one thing that you won't
break
under no circumstances for loco
you're ready for lunch amen like when it
first came out i used to drink that in
college
half a can out
you could feel the lead in that yeah you
could feel it
i knew a guy who used to shotgun me
serious bro used to shotgun the full
cans oh my god yeah he's not around
anymore no
all right so four local went out the
reports were coming back that blah blah
blah passing out okay yeah i think okay
go get them bring all the ones that are
left over you still maybe in the hood
we'll find a place oh my god it has a
couple of
a grape one and
a strawberry one in the back really i
don't buy one that sounds like a mission
the only thing they drunk in my head was
like saying that back in the day guys
remember saying that i haven't found the
stuff that i wouldn't at least try once
you know they tried this all right it
was pretty
it was though
like before they like redesigned it and
made it like lighter no the original
that was crazy okay four local you you
don't know
i don't drink you ever have a hangover
i've had one sip of alcohol in my life
my blessing and it was mike's heart and
i said i can't do this good for you
i didn't like it maybe i should have
tried something else
you don't have a chance of looking like
me then
what what what are you uh is there
anything you you will not have again no
nothing i'll try if somebody says hey
once you try it i'll i'll try i'll give
it a shot they said virgo will you try
it
is that a vegetable
you swallow the wine
if
they're still around crazy horse i'll
never touch it again that's the only
time praise yours that's the only day
that's the only time i i ever felt that
way and the next day i felt like
happened i had to work the next day
the big beer was uh black label that's
the only thing you can get over there
something called black label and i
wasn't a beer drinker so i never i never
drank it one of the guys in my unit
uh when this helicopter was down the
rocket pods it went out yeah he painted
him duplicate a cooler scan
send it home to his dad pictures his dad
he lives in arizona his dad sent it to
course coors sent two pallets of coors
beer to his house saying thank you very
much
yeah he did
call him
beer company you know what year that was
1978 you know what they call that drink
right
they call that drink in england
ashanti
i thought i made that [ __ ] up on the on
your golf course when i was playing one
of your tournaments i took i took like a
corona and a sprite and i was like oh
this [ __ ] is delicious i made my own
drink until my mommy came up to me and
goes that's called the shanty i was like
oh thank you so we were playing golf
when we were playing golf years ago when
my show was on valencia played my friend
and nancy at lakeside
and uh
how do you shank and hit somebody in the
back like that this was off the tee box
no this one's in the right fairway
remember uncommon valerie where the
guy's drawing and he goes ah he's on his
knees
hit him in the back
like that boys in the hood and he said
and he said no go ahead platoon i was
like yeah
it was a part three or what
part four look like oh so it had some
speed speed bro
i was like
[Applause]
somebody's trying to shoot you like no
and he even said no go ahead i'm cool
i'll get out of the way [ __ ] drop
them drop me bro i was on the ground
that was one of my favorite he didn't
let you go he let you get out of there
cuz fast man yeah but i trusted him he
was like where you are but like get
about 50 feet away and i'm here like
okay go for it it was like boom i was
like what the [ __ ] how did you not break
something like breakfast
i was lucky it sliced me just oh you got
scared i got skinned bro i didn't get
like dead i got skipped and i was like
that
what the heck
i tell everybody when the movie's coming
out
the 10th
february 10th north of the 10 bt plus
get it on uh what on your apps on your
phone and you're everywhere everywhere
socials
everywhere on
that's a sight actually you know that
right oh yeah back in the day they had
black planet and then they fought for
the latinos they had migente
yeah it was just it was actually a site
right it was pretty popular back in
there and then myspace
a buddy of mine
said the reason people continue to like
it as i
through the department went up
he said because
you're hinted that's all you are you
you're not any better than anybody else
you're hinted and that's
why everybody likes you sometimes
i'm just
regular folk and then they told me to
shine these shoes so we can go find that
nightstand there you go all shiny shoes
he found the legend man this
thanks for asking me to be in that thank
you man
good luck cheers
appreciate it
okay let's go
you